- Mais samedi, la route,
je sais qu'elle était peut-être
le lait aurait dû être ramassé.
un producteur laitier en colère.
Cela fait plusieurs jour
qu'il n'a pas vu le camion
qui vient habituellement
Dimanche, il a appris
qu'à cause de ememempête,
le camion ne passerait pas.
Résultat : il a dû jeter
MICHEL BEAULIEU,
producteurlalalait
- Là, en dessous, ici,
on a ouvert ça. Ça s'est jeté
dans le trou, là, tout le lait,
puis la pompe mpmpmpé ça
dans le seau à fumier.
rien. On n'a pas d'assurance,
rien pour ça. C'est...
l'absorber puis continuer.
- M. Beaulieu chiffre
la perte financière
de ne pas être indemnisé.
Il dit n'avoir jamais vécu
une telle situation en 35 ans
de la crise du verglas.
- En 1998, on a été 23 jours
perdu un litre de lait.
Il y avait 4 pouces
On a eu, je pense, une petite
tempête à comparer à 98,
de pas ramasser le lait.
- Par courriel, la PDG
de l'Ontario nous a indiqué
que l'absence de certains
transporteurs était inévitable,
en raison des violen
hivernales à travers l'Ontario.
Elle ajoute que :
Michel Beaulieu, lui,
estime que ça
estime que ça n'augure
rien de bon pour le futur.
- Je crains qu'à chaque fois
de glace, on va être obligés
de jeter notre lait. Comment
vous voulez qu'on arrive?eeeeeee
voir à la prochaine tempête
qu'est-ce qui va arriver.
- Nous avons contacté
le transporthehehehehehehehehehr
le lait, mais il ne veut
faire autatatatatataire.
Le producteur laitier, lui,
exige toujours une explication.
Radio-Canada, à Sainte-Anne-de-
Prescot